Good afternoon, I am one of the
interpreters.  If anyone needs
interpretation into Spanish, come with
us.  Here we have
headphones for you to listen to the
presentation entirely in Spanish.
Thank you so much.
If you could write down your name and phone number,
please.
Let's begin.
Welcome.  My name is [name], I am the director
here in Palm.  [applause]
[ovation]
Thank you all for being here.
I know it's difficult to come here after
classes.
I would like to welcome you.  Just a
few reminders before we
begin.  We have childcare.
Hey, Miss Anderson, Miss Gomez.
Hey, they have games there, they have music,
they have snacks.  So, if they want
their children to go to daycare,
they can take them there.  And we also
have restrooms here on the right
, they're open.  So, if
you need to go, please, you can go
ahead.  And now let's begin.  Um,
I want to welcome you and I'm going to
give the floor to Superintendent
Matias
who is here to answer our
questions and we have 90 minutes for this
meeting.
So, Miss Ali is going to
speak now.
Thank you very much, director.  Uh, hi, my
name is Ali Guilarducci and I'm the director
of communications and
community engagement.  This is our agenda.  Okay,
we're going to talk about the board's rules,
and
then we're going to have the opportunity
for the people here to
answer questions,
and I want everyone to familiarize themselves
with the plan we have and the
reason why we're
making these decisions
and having these conversations.
And we want to be able to answer
some of the questions you
have here in person and also
through the comment cards.
Okay, so we're going to start
answering that before we move on to the
in-person questions,
and then we'll talk about the
next steps, and that's it.  As
for the rules,
ah, we're here
to acknowledge the difficulties we
're having with all of this.
Ah, we want stronger and more equitable schools,
and we're going to ask you to try to
limit your comments to one minute so
that everyone who wants to participate
can do so. We want to respect the
process
of following the agenda so that we can
hear from everyone,
and we may disagree with
certain ideas, but we want to maintain
a positive intention.
Ah, because we want to create
schools that are solid and have
sufficient resources for all
students.
Ah, if anyone wants to talk, let them
all and they've already spoken once.  Oh,
please wait for other people to
speak first.
Oh, and we're
here
to embrace transparency and
empathy.  These are
difficult conversations.  Oh, and we're going to face
them with compassion and honesty.
The purpose of today's meeting,
uh,
is to
answer some of those
frequently asked questions you may have
about our plan, and we want to
know what things you're proposing and
why.  And as the leadership team,
we want to hear your ideas
to refine the plan we
have,
and we'll have an edited version of
that plan.
Uh, and then we can use all
those comments that you've left us in
person and through the
feedback card.
And now we're going to ask the superintendent to
say a few words.  Thanks,
Ali.
I am very grateful that you all
came this afternoon and that we are having
this conversation.  As Ali said, this
is a draft of the plan and it's really
important that our community
gives us their feedback before we take the next step.  And I also
want to acknowledge how difficult this is.
Ah, these are very
difficult changes, they
are sad
and I want to apologize that we have to go through
this.
Never is something I never thought I would have to
do as
superintendent
and it's not something I want to do.  The
reality
is that in Austin ISD
we have some schools,
and we have certain strong schools
in East Austin, but the
truth is that we don't have
strong schools everywhere.
And in those 144 years that have led us to
where we are,
we have made decision after decision
and in the
end
the students have not received what they
needed to succeed.
The board and I
are on the same page that all
students should have what they
need.
And each student has different
needs.  But to do that we need to
think
about how we work, what resources we have,
and be honest about what has
changed.  And we have to do all of that right now
with public education facing
challenges from all sides.
So, what we want is to have
strong neighborhood schools that
all students have
access to.
What we want is for students to
love learning, not just to be
good at taking a test.  We want
students to feel comfortable
in their own skin.  We want
students to
feel that being multicultural is a
superpower, and to do that we need
resources in every school.  So, this
plan we have
addresses all of that
in a very complex way and with several
levels.  The first thing
is that it tries to align the
remission patterns.  And when I talk about that,
what I want is for elementary school students to
not go to more than one or two high schools
in order to keep the community together.
and that high school students then
go to no more than one or two
preparatory schools.  Right now in
Austin we have middle schools that
go to four or five
high schools.
Can you guess where those
schools are?  They are in East Austin.   We
also have many schools
that go 100% to their middle or
high school.  Can you guess where
those schools are?  So, this plan
is intended to realign all
referral patterns across Austin.
And ultimately we want to keep
communities together, we want to align
programs, and if we do that we think
we'll be in a better position in the
long run.  And number two, the cost of
education has increased year after year, and
in recent years
the State has not helped us
in the way I think they
should have.
Ah, changes at the federal level have affected
title one, title two, and
title three funds.
We have to pay the teachers so they can
live in this community,
and we're going to keep doing it.
But as we do that, it puts
pressure on the system because everything costs
money.  So, to be more
efficient,
we need to see where
our system is misaligned, and that's why
we're making consolidations and
changes to the boundaries.
Three.
eh alignment of programs.
Dual language is something we
believe in here in Austin.
There are school districts all over
Central Texas
that are
n't doing it, but we
want to.  But to do it
right, we have to make sure
that the programs for which the
students were
designed are there.  And
right now we have programs that are not
balanced,
we have to move the programs to
where the students are.
The other thing we have to consider
is that we are in a
state accountability system that is much
larger than our school district.  I would
never, ever, ever say
that these letters they are putting
on our schools determine who
our schools are.  They are the ones
who assign those fs and ds uh uh
based on a single test that has been
taken on a single day in most
cases.  And the reality is that I have to
guarantee that we as a system
overcome that and break those chains of
responsibility.  And if we don't, if we do
n't address that real risk that comes
with responsibility, we could
potentially lose the ability to
educate our students in the
way we believe is
right.
The members of its board of directors
determine the direction we are
going in.  They are elected locally.
So this plan also has to
take into account that
liability risk that exists in the TinD.
If we don't change the system, at some
point
this district is going to look very different,
and I'm not going to let that happen.  The
other thing included in this plan is changes
to the transfer rules.
In Austin, there have
been many rules that have been in place
for decades
that allow a student to move from
one part of the city to another.
Transfers have been controlled by
the schools because that creates fairness.
Why do we have so many students who
live in East Austin who
then want to go to Austin High School?
This plan is taking all of this into account,
and we're going to have those conversations with
you
to move forward as a
school system, because one of the things we can't
do is fail to recognize this
real risk that exists in our
school system.
Because what I don't want to take away from
our staff or our families
is the right to choose.
I'm going to make those
tough decisions, but I do
n't want to be more disruptive than I
need to be.  So, these are the
things that are going to happen in Palm.  Ah,
Palm Elementary,
I know it has an amazing principal.
Ah, everyone does amazing things.  Ah, they have
performed better each year, but the
reality is that there are not enough
students living here now.
All the students in this area,
all those who come to Palm, we still
couldn't fill this school.
So, if we think as a system,
how can we balance it?
Ah, this plan includes Palm Elementary
[clears throat] going all to Perez.
And the reason that's important
is because when we can keep the
whole community together, we want to.  We don't
want to separate Palm School, we don't
want to send them to different schools
and separate them into several schools.
The other thing I want to point out, and we'll
talk more about that in a moment,
is the staffing.
I want our community to know that
whatever the transition, I
have promised time and time again that everyone
working at TinD will
have a home.   There have
been some messages out there
saying that they are going to lose their jobs.
That's not true.
As we proceed, it
may be that we don't
have as much
flexibility.
Uh, but we're going to have these
conversations with the staff,
but I want the community to know that I
recognize that the only reason
I exist is to support
educators.  That's all.  Ah, this is the plan
we're going to talk about here.
Ah, this will be implemented next
school year.
So, we have the entire
spring semester to plan, to work
with both school communities,
and then we'll implement it on
the November vote.
We wanted to hear from all of you, to have
a conversation
about how we should consider our
buildings, our schools in general.
So
we have some of the questions that were given to us
in advance, starting with
Ricardo.  The school is an
inhabited part of our community, and closing it would
disrupt students, break
important relationships with teachers,
and create
more difficult, longer commutes.  The
district has explored other options and
may delay this decision.  Well,
we've had many options
over the last few months, many months,
a plan, and the reality is that we simply do
n't have
the resources we need here.  So,
to stabilize
our community, we need to have an
area large enough to fill the
school, so we can focus all our
resources here.  It may be
delayed, it
could be delayed, but I'm not going to, I'm
not going to put that in and this is the reason.
I'm not going to put it on.  We are
facing a budget deficit.
We are taking some
transition risks, liability risks,
all of which
cost resources.  It really does
.  So let's do all this
together.
This strategy must be an all-in-one approach
.
so that they form a complete system and take all
the steps together.  So,
if any of these are removed, it
means that the risk for next year
will increase, because I'm not going to
propose a plan of change for
the spring and we'll talk about that.  If
we do something in the spring, it will be
more difficult for our staff who
have relied on it.  Our family will not
have everything it needs to
prepare for the rest of the year.  We already saw
what happened to Martin in sixth grade halfway through
.  They left in April in Martin.
Schools and families were all in
disarray, and they had two and a half months
to really get us back together and
put everything back together, and it never really worked.
So I don't want to
fail and do something that's not in
alignment with all of you.
So my strategy, my approach is to
take one vote together in November,
we have time to plan it.  If there is a
delay,
it's forward by a year, and at that
point, all the other things we're
trying to avoid in terms of risk are
coming to the surface.  That's why we
're not looking at delaying this at the
moment.
The next question is
from the manager.  If Palm closes, Dan
would continue to reside at his
current location and the R students would continue
to attend classes on laptops
located at Palm, while the
Palm building is vacant.
So, if this is one of those
transition questions
that we're going to encounter, then I
can tell you that if Palm were to close
in the 2027 school year
and the building were vacant, we
would look at whether there was an opportunity to
reduce the cost of keeping LANF on
laptops,
because that also has a cost.  So
any
way we collectively lower
our costs is always good;
it's better to try to use buildings
instead of laptops.
So I can see this, all this is
possible, whether it's Lford or Palm or
laptops, but I can't say that we
would be seeing
an interim space solution,
as long as it lowers the cost.
So, this would be a bad service
for these laptops
that are [clears throat] right outside the
school building.  Once again, I don't know
how we're going to be doing.
The next question
is from Ret.  Have you considered combining
Luar and Palm?  And what is the
thought process behind closing or reassigning Palm
to Pérez and not Blazer?  And why
did the district choose to close Palm instead of
changing the boundaries from Blazer to Palm?
Okay, so we've seen Palm and
Langford, and one of the things I want
to mention and that I want you to know is that he's, let's say, halfway there
.  When
we look at the limits,
we have to see exactly where they are.
So, as you can see, this is
Perez,
this is Palm.  And this is Lford.  So,
in order to connect the two,
we would have to create
this very strange shape
or we would have to create a
broken or divided boundary zone, which is what we do
n't want to do.
So, once again looking at the
logistics,
the preferred approach
is to join two adjacent boundaries or
together.
We were able to see all this and I'm going to tell you
that the amphitheater
is relatively full, so we wouldn't be able to
relocate all of Pum.  And one of
the things we feel very
strong about is that we want to create a
safe and secure space.  I think that's
one of the trade-offs we had to
make.  The school is a
little further away, but we want to know
that the community will be a
very small percentage that would have to be affected
in that way.  The other question was
Blazer.  So, Blazer is to the south and
these schools
are on the Austin shore and Palm
is not far from Blazer.  Blazer is
just south of here.  So, we can't
change
Blazer's attendance limits
because the school is in the nearby area that
includes the area.
Therefore, we cannot include a school
that is not within the
attendance limits.  So, Blazer is here.
Blazer is here just to the south,
but Blazer goes all the way south, all the way to Cris.
So if P were to move just a little bit
for six or seven blocks, it would start to
be within the
attendance limits, it would start to consume the
BL area.  So, we can't do that.
The school must be within the limits
of attendance.  So, this is
simply a function of the locations,
the maps that were made years and
years ago.  So, there really isn't
a solution because we have a boundary
with the east, basically with Del Valle.
Yes, thanks.
Oh, so I just wanted to add that
when we look at the schools and we look at the
boundaries, we start preparing and seeing
where our students live and
we want to make sure that they are okay.
So, when we looked at this group, this
area, we saw the boundaries,
we have between six and seven schools.
with more than 5000 issues with only
3600 students.  So, we have to
see what capacity we have in the
schools that were accommodated
and then what will be a healthy thing.
So, where do we begin?
Then we look at those locations where
our schools are and where
our students live and we see how many
seats are available.
[cough]
And I think a question of
and then is being developed.
So it's simply this pressure being
exerted by its limits.
There are some questions here.
I was here with the first meeting in
P.
Then the children were there.
My question is, I've seen them
sonify the other area.  So I don't
understand the justification for us being able to
send children from Palm.  I live on
a street, a few blocks from Palm.
Blazer is right next door.  Why can't we
go north of Blazer
and east of Blazer
and take you and send you towards
Plaughter
Lane is still our limit.
So in 5 years we'll have
Blazer, which will already be full and they'll be
using the buses by then
.  And what are they going to do
at that moment?  Five years will be a
different school.
So, if we saw that, [applause]
then
remember, the whole school is
visible.  The question is,
how are we going to get closer to
where we want to end up?  So, my
understanding is that we're going to
see how it's going to
work.  We'll have to go into
Blazer's pretty deep limit.
I am very familiar with this area.
I can provide that data, but when we
saw it, it was a very definite number because
much of that area
is quite large, so there are
many open spaces.
One
has to go down in order to raise a
number of students and be able to raise the
number.
So, we really need to get up to
hundreds of students, which is what we
're thinking about, but we'll gladly
look at that and see that in more depth.
I wanted to talk a little bit about that comment
about
projection.  We are making
10-year projections
with developers, builders, and
others.  We are looking at a
10-year approach and we all have these
projections
and we are going to be able to see those
projections up to that point
and there are some policies that have already been
honored and established
and how that is being used.   I'm
going to go back and forth so
that the questions that are there are
because they are questions prior to this and I
hope this is really okay.
So, nobody is arguing that
CL isn't doing well, what we're saying
is that you're saying they can't
see those children because many of those
children are being pulled by the
limit of the blazer.  We can't take
children out of Blazure, can we
?  We don't want the
bread boundary to go so far south that it's going
around Blazer.
But what we do want, [snort] I don't
know if that's fair.  So they're
telling us that when he thinks about it,
Blazer might enter this building
because he could die.
And then you're seeing parents
who live here walking past the school,
passing by what used to be their
original school, Pérez and others, when it's
just that some of those kids from
Blazer come here, but because they do
n't want to mess around, they don't want to bother
the...
That's not true.  That's not true.
[snort]
Let's look at all the solutions.
No, no, it's not just because I don't want to
do that.
What is a sufficiently large area where I can
bring the student population for
the next 10 years that can be
supported?
So, the community here is talking about how
the Blazer community has exploded, and that's why
you're building another school, and
we've gone downhill, especially after
the flood that
took away so many homes.
So, if we had obtained any
of those families from the beginning,
then there's no reason why we
couldn't have those children coming
here.  It's easier for the children to
come from school over there
than for the bread children to go all the way over
there.  Most of our dads
walk too, so I don't understand.
So when I'm sitting here
when you say that, then that's not
really what I heard.
So, I don't understand why we can't
do that.
[applause]
I think
what we want to see is
the question, right?  A couple of
students fail to solve the problem.   It
has to be a large area.   It's
not just about who lives there.
[snort]
Ah, we need to see the projections.
We did an analysis of how much area
we had to cover
and we're trying to move away from that,
right?  And that's why we're in
this situation right now, because in
recent years we've added this
school, we've jumped this area over
here, so I don't want to
just do what other people
have done if it doesn't make sense for
our community.  Now,
let's say we have space and we could
make it work.
I'm trying to see
how we can make adjustments to support
the needs
and overcome the pressure
we're under right now.
But I don't want to create the expectation
that, oh, we're going to use Blazer, which is right
here, and that's going to solve all
the problems.
And I appreciate your comment about the
limits because we've heard that from
other schools.   There is
no regular review process.
Austin simply wants to change
drastically,
but
I think this is our first
strategy.   We do
n't want to be in the situation we
've been in for the last few decades.
We want to do a process,
uh, uh,
nothing more, because they are expanding
a lot.  We don't want to do the
same thing that happened to Leander and
other districts.
So, the next question is, is the
traffic on William Canon a cause for
concern?  Could you explain if
transportation will be provided to
students changing school zones?
Our transport policy will remain the
same.
If you live more than 2 miles from the school you
have to attend, you will need
transportation.
Or if the route is deemed
dangerous, we will also provide a
bus for that student.
Oh, sorry, I'm going to ask a question.
So, you are going to have a bus, I
like it?
I am a mom who moves.  How is
that going to work for our children?
How is that going to work, huh, regarding the
transfers?  That's one of the things we
're addressing as part of this
update to our plan, to be
very clear, because we want
families who have moved to the
school, if they're already used to
coming to this school, to be able to
continue.  So, that's one of the
things that wasn't clear in the
initial draft, and it wasn't clear because there were so
many hypothetical situations that we had to
work through.  Ah, but in
the new version we're going to have a whole
document that says about the
transfer rules and students who have
transferred to a school will be
kept
with the entire school's curriculum.
So, if your child comes to Palm
right now and the whole group goes to Perez,
you'll be able to go to Perez
automatically.  Does it make sense?  That's what we
're trying to do now,
because those things are not
consistent with our values.  Oh, and
then
, correct me if I'm wrong.
Why can't we combine Langford
with Palm?
No, it wouldn't fit
when you say combine.  I was wondering if
here or Palm doesn't fit within Lford
because
Langford,
but Pérez has the same number of
students.
Each school has a different capacity.
Not all schools are the same
size, nor can they admit the same
number of students, as Blazer and
Lford are very different.  So,
we need to think about how many students
they have right now and how many students
can be safely accommodated to support those
programs.  So,
looking at it from that perspective, I don't
remember exactly the capacity of each
school, but each school has a
different capacity.
And I also want to know if
there are teachers who have lots of
students, if
there are teachers who have more than 20
students in their class.  So, I just
want to know, they
keep talking about budget and
budget and budget.
What I would like to say
is that 22 students is the maximum they
can have.   It
's the 22nd.
I
want to explain to you how the budget
affects us.  Ah, we don't
have educators in our classrooms
where we need them.  We have
vacancies,
we need to support students
with intervention specialists,
content specialists, so that
all children have everything they
need in line with our values.
So what I'm saying is that
the budget is a big part of
this, but it's not the reason why we
make all the decisions.
The reason we exist is
to provide everything the
classes need.  But if I don't have the resources,
then all our students,
all our schools are not going to
succeed.
And right now
the federal government
has lost millions of dollars,
the cost of education has increased.
We lost 100,
we've lost so much money and we've
tried to recover money in
recent years, but we're deciding to
keep certain things in our
schools.  We have
decided to have things that the State does not
necessarily require.
Ah, we could have a
different curriculum and save ourselves 6 or 7 million
dollars, but if the curriculum
is not in line with our values, we don't
want it.  So, it's not that I'm
only thinking about it from a
financial perspective, but the reality
is that if we can't have a
balanced budget, the risk of
the agency
not taking power is real.
And this question can really make
a difference.  How will the closure
of three schools affect the district's enrollment and
overall resources?  One
of the things we hear from time to
time is, "
Oh, if you close the schools, they're going to lose
students."  Another thing I see
is that right now we have schools
that are
not the school of choice for the
neighborhood children.
So, we have areas in Austin where there are
a lot of students.
Much of it is about many
families feeling that the
charter schools or the other school in the other
neighborhood is better.
So, what I want is to get
to the point where all schools
perform well
and we have the resources to do
it, to achieve it.   I ca
n't have 116 schools with the
budget we have,
and another pressure is enrollment.  Our
enrollment has decreased, decreased in
recent years,
and the problem is that there are families who
cannot afford, cannot afford the cost
of living in Austin,
and we have seen that over the last 10
years.
So, that's the problem: we
're not receiving
state funding.  So, if we're going to do something
right and have stronger schools,
we need to have fewer schools.  That's
the truth.
Um, to get back to the topic of
transportation,
there are several families in the community
who have disabilities
and who need special buses.
Currently there are no buses
for those students to get to
Pérez
and
we would have to drop our
students off at 6 in the morning to
be able to get to work on time
or I would have to find another job.
Ah, so what's the solution to
that?  The first thing I would say is that right now there is
still no bus route
because
this plan has not yet been implemented until the schools are combined
.
Uh, but as has been said, if it's
more than 2 miles away, it will automatically
have a bus.
So, I think that will
resolve itself
when the plan is implemented.
We didn't explicitly state
that in the first draft because it's
part of our rules, okay?
Oh,
and the other thing is that it's useful if we understand
that this community needs a different level of
support.
We, the district,
can make those changes.  We have
families all over the city.  We have
20,000 students who use our
buses.  Some schools
open very early.  Ah, we have
students who
come very early in the
morning because their families work.
But I need to know what needs to
change in the mindset or in the
system of the new school in order to be able to
support you.  That's the kind of
thing I need to know to help them
with the transition plan.
And
I am willing to do things
differently to support our
students.
So, ah,
on Friday we're going to have the framework for
the transition, you're going to see all the
things.  We'll be
working on these, how they're going, what's going to happen with
the PTAS,
oh, what are we going to do to honor the
school's legacy?  All those things.
And yes, there are
programs that
need to be there right now.
Oh, and we always provide transportation for
special education students
.  Ah, so if that's the case, you
can rest assured that we will
provide that transportation because it's a
separate system,
uh, it's not related to
state or federal regulations.  So,
students with special needs
always have transportation.
And then there are also several
commenters who mentioned this
question.  She says, "Our students
receiving special education services
are excelling and
improving. What considerations are you
taking into account for students
receiving special education services
?
Hi, my name is Kristen, and I'm the
executive director of
special education, and we certainly
want our students to
continue to improve. And the good news
is that Pérez has a
very strong special education program.
They have a lot of support and
services.
So, I don't think there will be
any disruption in services, and
that will be able to continue.
In the plan, we also have a
separate document that describes the
special education services and what
students can expect during the
transition.
If there are any services that don't exist
at that school, we'll
specify what's
in the plan.
But the special education support and
allocated resources,
that comes from the Department of
Special Education. Because
we allocate resources based
on need. So
, that's why it's important to talk about
all of this. I
want to go back to Lford. I was
passing by Lford,
and there isn't a building there right now."
And you were saying that Langford and Palm
together here is
n't possible, but before the
floods, we
were together. We used to have
all those students here together.
So, I don't understand
why, if they
sell that property and build a
solid school here,
right?
We're talking about this, right?
[snort]
So, no, it wasn't that long ago,
but what I'm going to say is that
with all the projects we've seen
and all those things, modernizing the
facilities,
that's something we're committed to
continuing to move forward,
and we're not going to say that all of that plays a
role in all of this.
So, we couldn't do it that way; it wouldn't have
been intentional.
Well, what happened to all of that? So,
the way the bond
is used for all the work, the bond dollars
can be reauthorized by the board of
trustees.
All the projects that are tied to Palm
Elementary. So, I'm
going to tell everyone, and all the
students
want to make sure in all the
buildings that there's water and that the air
conditioning is working.
So, many times we knew—I didn't
know—that
the state offered support.
So,  Throughout this time,
we want our children to feel
safe, supported, and have a good
learning environment. So, what we
did was
work with the building oversight committee
. So,
if the students see Pérez,
then what's happening at Pérez?
What can be removed? What can be
added, and so on. And then, in some
cases, in
some cases where
the facilities are being relocated,
the question is, can they be moved
to another school,
or can they be moved later to high
school or preparatory school?
And then, as long as
the equipment is maintained vertically so that all
students experience that investment
throughout their school years,
I would simply give the
recommendation of how this works.
The next question is from Tania B,
but I think,
well, let's ask your question.
My name is Antonio Vázquez, and I have
a fifth-grade student
at Palm.
So,
I'm glad that question came up
because it's next to another question
I have, but according to your rubric,
we were given a three. So,
seeing that three,
how did we get voted out
of a school? That goes  to be closed,
and let's say the school closes. What
happens after that?
So, are they going to
sell it, and if so,
how much is the district going to get
? The rubric,
as I mentioned during the process, was never going to
be
a list of schools to close. It never
was.
We said that time and time again.
We wanted to see that our system wasn't aligned
.
There are schools at the
top of that list that are going to be
consolidated in these ways. So it
impacted all the schools. That's why it was
n't that they voted
for it because it was P; it was looking region by region in
our school system
to see the overall goals of the plan,
which is what made sense. We have a
lot of open seats in this part
of Austin, and we do
n't want to do this. So, when we
confronted them,
at no point along the way did
we make a conscious decision that we're going
to close this school because it's
more or less valuable. This
was never part of the process.
So, what we do in this
process
is how the community has been.
So, since the 2019 bond, how has
the community space been, and other
Things? How did they look? And then
we were able to close the loop
and we said, this is the process we're
probably going to go through. It's not going to
happen without everyone's input.
If we don't have input from the entire
community, it's not going to happen. I would say it does
have to be balanced
because I want it to be
something that's open and transparent. Well, this is
fine, but
there are a lot of opportunities that we can really
explore.
How can we get back to families, to
our schools? That would be really great.
So, with these processes, I'm
simply taking the lead from the
community.
Sometimes they want to do things
faster, sometimes they want to do them
slower.
We want to make sure that students
are enrolled, that they're incorporated. That's what we
saw.
So, the conversation was around
housing.
So, we're trying to address the
need for more living space, and there are about
600 units that are
currently being built,
and at some point, value is taken into
account, or something like that, to be
considered in the process. Oh,
the question is, will the
school board consider pausing the
panorama closure to allow the community
time  to collaborate and explore
solutions that can increase
the number of enrolled students and
better serve our students.
So, I want to make sure everyone
understands that the most important thing is
that the administration makes a
recommendation,
and we're going to present that recommendation
to the board, and the board
has to make recommendations, and
they'll have to make some adjustments
in different areas.
So, a question really for
our board, I think we
can ask why, because
we need this. Yes.
So, I would simply say that
we can use a lot of resources,
but if the schools aren't within
the limits, they're going to be able to see.
So, we're going to be able to see what
we want to see. I've been working
on this a lot for some time now. How
can we help the whole system?
So, I'll tell the board, they
could make a little more
space, they could wait another year or two,
and then we can be like this.
So, the things they've been
doing,
so we're much more than
30% full. It did
n't have much to do with the flooding in
2019, but there are things that are not under
our control. So, I'm
trying to do what  as best we can and
establish all the opportunities that
are in front of us to avoid the risk of
this closing. We have a question in
Spanish.
My question is, good afternoon. Yas will be
with us. Are they
planning to close? I'm
also thinking about closing Win, and it's
another school that's very close to
us. I'm realizing that they're
going to close
Widen. It's a school very close to
us,
and there are reasons why
they want to close our school
because we have few students. I've
considered moving the students from
WID to Palm
. We've considered giving the students from Win to Palm.
So,
we haven't seen
the student numbers from Wil to
Palm
because of the limit issue I was
mentioning.
And so what I can say is that
each one is a very different situation,
and Widen has been in school for
multiple years, three,
without having achieved the
necessary accountability. I mean, it has a series
of Ds or FS that now require
us, AustinD, to develop a
plan that the State has to approve.
So, to do that, there are certain
things that need to be done. Where are
the schools going to go? It has to be a
school that is  If things are going well, then
P could qualify. Number two, the
systems put in place in the schools have
to meet the plan, and that may include
some teachers being required to have a
certain number of years of experience. This
could also be clearly articulated
and defined
in the processes throughout the
school year. So it's going to be much
tighter,
and what we're going to have to do is,
when most of the
Wid Ban shelves are in place, that's where that transformation plan is going to be
. Then they go north
to Houston and south
to Rodriguez.
So we've already thought about this and everything.
Not everyone was the same; that's why Win
is structured this way. I'd gladly
see if there's an opportunity,
but I don't think it's an opportunity
for everyone, but I'd gladly look at it again
. One question here.
I'm the teacher here,
and I noticed that no one has mentioned the
problem with
all the Yura construction.
What are they going to do if all
our students are in Perez and
our parents can't get there
when it floods again? And that was a
problem. We couldn't get our
students out of there to go to the other
side of the creek and cross. So, that  It's going to
happen again. And what are we going
to do?
I'm very familiar with that, the
floods, and the sequence of events
that occurred at that time,
and that's a very valid concern.
It's a very valid concern. So,
for us, we want that
transition planning because if they
go to another school, then
the families will still want
our students at Pérez.
So, for us, it's much
bigger than just one school.
So, how can we support all
our families
in an emergency response?
So, we
went through all of that. I do
n't have
the specific documents because it's been a
while since we discussed all of this,
and it's one of the things we did
together. It has to be articulated,
communicated, and shared with the entire
community.
So, if something is going to be
done, it's something we have to do.
So, we're going to receive the plan
you're talking about before November.
Most of the parents here,
and the other parents...
Our problem isn't going to another
school.
So, as you're saying, we can
go to our
school for our children.
We can go, but not always, as long as it's
something good for our school.
So, the thing is  The location, more
than anything.
Many of our children have
PTSD from what happened.
My children were in water
almost up to their knees. I had to
pull my children out of the
mud, and that was right in front of that
creek. So, again, they're
not going to give us the plan before
November. They're going to give us the
plan after they've made their
decision because then they'll have made
the plan without
taking us into consideration. What I would say is
that we can't make the plan unless we
have time to talk with all of you
here. I'm not saying you don't
have a chance, and your
lived experiences help me
understand what's needed so we can
respond properly. We haven't
taken the vote, so I know the
community has this plan, and we can
all plan together, but we haven't
reached a point where we can
just do it because we're still
in the process. But what I
can do is, based on all
the adjustments
and the Creek Watch,
I want to acknowledge
the trauma that occurred in that space, in
that  It's important to
have a response plan, but there's
nothing I can say that will
guarantee this won't
happen again. So, I mean, if this happens again
, Austin, tell me, what are you
going to do? How are you going to
respond to what happened between 2013 and 2015?
I can't say I can't
guarantee it won't happen again
. That's why I'm not
saying we're not going to do it. I can
elaborate on that and
answer your questions, but as for
a detailed plan of how
this community will operate, I have to ask
Pérez. I ca
n't present a
completely clean situation.
So, what I think we're going to
do is what we're
considering. This is what the
community said, this is what was recommended
by the board and the
superintendent, and it's all the work that's been
done, and we're putting it on the table.
So, this is how we're going to operate,
and I apologize, but that's the best that can be
presented.  to be done in
spaces.
Then I could do a report.
I'm going to ask that we go in order because
there are people who have been waiting to
comment.
Uh,
hi, I'm Karen Hot.
Oh, and I was here when we did
n't have the laptops yet. Oh,
but it's going to be built in Langford. And
when are they proposing that be done?
Because originally it was going to be built,
but it was going to take two and a half years. Oh,
but then, when are they proposing? Have they already
started? Oh, yes,
we went there and there's nothing there.
When we say it's started, just so
we understand, there's a lot
that has to happen before we see the
structure on the ground, but they have
started the
construction process.
Oh, it's an active construction site,
or because, well, no, if we want to keep
the whole Palma community together.
Oh, why are some kids from Pérez
going to Langford and Houston?
Thank you for that question.
If you look at the boundaries of Langford,
well, they're trying to balance
enrollment in the schools, and you're going to see, well, certain, certain
Additions to the
attendance areas.
I'm going to try as much as
possible to keep all the schools
together,
but... I don't
want to, we ca
n't keep all the
communities together
because we wouldn't be able to balance
enrollment. That's the truth.
So, we've been
refining the plans, making
adjustments.
We could probably make it all fit
, etc., but if we hear from
the Pérez community, that this is a
concern in Pérez, we can make
certain adjustments,
or also add a separation
in middle or high school.
I have a child in Palm.
And my question is,
when you drive around there, there are
new apartments.
So
why can't the
boundaries be adjusted to include those areas,
those zip codes?
The first thing I want to say
is that when we're talking about
boundary changes between Palm and Blazer
and the difficulties we've had, it's
very far north and Palm is very far
south.
So, the Palm boundary would include
Blazer Elementary.
Now I want to see what opportunities
exist,
but we
would have to move hundreds of children to
rebalance the  Schools.
I'm open to exploring it,
but I know Bedicheck well.
This is a very difficult situation
because between Covington, Méndez, Paredes,
Henry Lively, and Bedicheck,
Bedicheck
also
has three schools under its jurisdiction.
So, we have to break that chain. There's
a real risk of
state intervention,
and they could take control of the board
. That already happened in Fort Worth,
and we're committed to having a
presence and rethinking what
Bedicheck is
and recognizing that any plan we
have,
we can consider that, but I can't do it
without some kind of change because
right now the pressure
is the risk of that responsibility.
So, I would never want to affect
families in this way.
I want to support everyone with the
transition. I know many of those children
will go to Covington, some to Paredes,
and some to Lively,
but then there are other schools that
also have three schools under their jurisdiction.
One of the things we're looking at is where they're
going and what changes need to
happen there.
But what I can say is that the state
of Texas  You have to accept our
plans.
Ah, recently,
this school year has been different
than the last. So, the transformation plan is
similar to Palm, which
is south of the district.
But the reason Bedicheck
works is because it has many schools
around it.
Um, then there's Mendez to the north and
Bedichec to the west, and well, it doesn't work, I
mean, it's too much. So, the only
reason Bedicheck is the
school is because it's surrounded by other
schools.
So, all of this comes into play. I
know it's not what you want to
hear,
but if I try to do it another way, it does
n't work.
I want to know,
have you counted how many children are going to lose?
Mine is in fifth grade.
Ah, after that, he probably won't go to
a public school anymore, but to a
charter school.
Um, I don't want him to go. Have you
thought about that? We've thought about a
lot of things.
Ah, because we've all been doing an
excellent job here. You all have
done an excellent job, but
why aren't we there from the
state's perspective?
If we put in all the resources, everything we
need, and we haven't seen
Growth,
let me, let me please finish my
thought. Um, we're at the point where
all of our schools need the
resources they need to succeed.
Whether you're in Palm Springs, Blackshier,
wherever you are.
My position is, if we have those resources
and we have great teachers
and students and the culture and
climate of everything.
I know families want the best
for their students,
but we also have to understand that there are going to be
transitions. I don't want to
make them, but I can't say that it's going to
be this percentage or this percentage.
Other districts
have done consolidations in Texas and
have seen a small change in
enrollment.
But I don't know how to respond to that.
Why does it take three years for you to
do something about it?
You're talking about EASD, right?
Um,
disruption matters; it has a big
impact on the system.
Um, we were talking about three FS 245, uh,
23, 24, and 25.
But this
board administration came in at the end of that year,
and we went from  From 72%
teacher retention
to
97.5%.
Now,
superintendent after superintendent
after superintendent,
and teachers and principals leaving
the job. Yes, we certainly should have
done more before, but I don't want you to
think we haven't changed this
system in recent years. We now
have instructional specialists that we did
n't have before.
We have an
aligned curriculum for the first time.
Because before, one school had one
experience, another school had a
different experience. We don't have
that anymore. We've seen improvements in
literacy and numeracy,
and we're not going in the
right direction. So, I would like us to
accept what's happening right now
and move forward
together.
I promise you I'm going to do whatever
needs to be done, even if it's difficult,
but I can't explain why things
happened years ago.
But I believe we're making
progress now.
If you haven't had a chance to speak,
raise your hand.
Anyone who hasn't spoken yet, who
wants to speak?
Okay, then I'll come back to you. I do
n't have the answer I
wanted  about Blazer.
No,
everyone knows it's
a good school,
but what I'm saying is,
I wish you would go and fight for
us.
You're going to Palm and Palm is an excellent
school.
When you talk about disruption,
if you could
give us 100 children, we'd take them.  If they
give us those 100 children, then we don't have to
go to Pérez and Pérez doesn't have to be
separated.  They can leave Pérez there,
right?
So that they don't have to keep
moving and there will be less disruption.   I do
n't understand why they
have more than 12 children.
Why can't you go there and say as a
community, '
Hey, let's take these kids to Palm?'
So that wasn't a
community decision.
We are teaching exactly
the same thing they are teaching there, and we don't
have those 3 years with Efes.  So,
yes, it seems very simple
to
say, "Oh, this is what we have to
do."
But I feel like you're just trying
to sell it.
Ah, we know it's just like
the salesman's spiel
, right?
Ah, but you
really did talk to us
because there were like seven, there were
so many questions and they only
put like seven.   to
be the end of the world.   It's going to
be difficult for those parents to
come here or drive 3
more minutes, or like this mother here who
lives right next door
and won't be able to do that with her
child anymore.
[applause] I
'm not trying to be a salesman.
Ah,
I'm just here
for myself,
I really want to communicate that these are
real risks we have,
budget risks.
So, it's not that I'm trying to
sell it, it's that I'm saying we
have to do something different from what we
've done in the many
previous decades.
I have no problem making
difficult decisions.  I'm going to look for
opportunities, I'm going to talk to the
communities, and I'm going to tell them what
I think is best.  But there are
certain things we've identified
as goals or strategies,
and that creates difficulties,
right?  So, I have no problem going over that again
.
Oh, and one of the things we talked about,
I know that
different children are assigned to
different high schools.
and they also divide when they go to high
school.  So, all of this is
something we're talking about when it comes to aligning
referral patterns.
Ah, so this is what we're going to
do, but all these other things aren't going
to be compromised.
So, I have no problem.  If
you want us to look at it, I can re-
evaluate it,
but it's the total number of places in the
area.
So, let's say we took
students out of Blazer.
We'll still have the same number of places
available in the area, right?
No, we haven't deleted anything, we just
moved them from one place to another.
So,
uh, certain decisions were made years ago
, right, when
they built Blazer.
So, those are the things I
want to be honest about.
I want to explore, I'm committed to
having difficult conversations.
I'm going to do my part to support them.
They have to build a school
for us,
and so here we are.
285 of us.
So, nobody does anything, nothing gets done.   They
are sending buses for the
students.
So, our children are going to drip.
My daughter had to change her clothes to be
able to come here.
So, I don't understand why this
happened.
One of the things they do is we look at the
process and evaluate it in a couple of years
because I don't want to be here in 5 or
6 years.
This is very painful, this is very hard.   They are
setting those limits to
try to optimize them.  Families move away
, new developments are built, and
everything changes.   We
all have to accept that we'll be taking a break for
20 years,
but I hope to have that conversation
later.
There are some schools that are 44 years old.
So,
we're doing everything we
want to address.
So, one of these is
processes that are already in place.
We only have about 7 minutes left
and we have to stop because we have
another community meeting after
this.  Then
we'll ask you your questions and we'll do it for you
.
A question.  So, at our
last strategy meeting,
they said that 40% of the students and
40% of the staff should be on that campus.
So, the students who see
Pérez, 100% of them should be moved,
change direction that way.  That's how it's going to
work.  Yes. One of the things I would
say is that if
there is a larger population, there needs to be
a larger group of
teacher trainees.
What percentage will they have in that
new school?  What percentage of Pérez
is new?
So what percentage of them will be
taken into account?
So it
's 50% of the total staff
of a completely
different population.
If we combine the schools, 50%
of the total spa operations
and 50% of
Pérez's teaching distribution will go to P.
So
100% of the school and the new school is
much larger
where there are 500 and the school that is coming 150
v something like 22% something like that.
So, our director, we've already had
the conversations, they know that
we want
our community to know that we are being
very intentional in our use
of staff, and
so there isn't a specific rule of
how we're doing it.
We never avoided those
conversations.
So, it doesn't mean that this
director is going to be hiring
a lot of people just so that
50% of the Pérez staff will go towards.
So, some teachers will have to
leave because
we're going to be reorganizing our
schools.
So, it's not always going to be
something super precise, like 50/50 or something,
but whenever there's a new school,
there's a percentage
that will leave and we'll have to add
staff and hopefully it will continue to be
a new
[clears throat]
distribution.
So, if that's going to be true in
any case and in any
school, then it's what's going to be best for
our students.
Yes, yes, 100% everything.
So, in the essential areas, yes, of
course.  So, the essential areas
would be very similar, let's say,
a very large student population
and there is a distribution for
physical education.
So, how would we do it?
When the staff office comes,
because most elementary schools
have
the same layout, regardless of the
school's size.
So we have areas where we
students
want the person to be the same
school principal whenever
possible, and we're going to be very intentional about that.
We're going to talk to each other and
we'll have some intentions.  But what I do
n't want to do is
create an environment where
families
or staff from outside the school are going to be
considered for a school.  This
will be our last question.
So, speaking of projections,
they're closing Palm.
Blazer is about to explode.  What are they
going to do in 10 years
with the ever-
growing population?
You're going to need schools that
stay open
to accommodate those new
populations that are here, and this school
will continue to be necessary.  Well, yes.
So,
south of Slaughter
there are thousands of things, as they mentioned,
that are coming out.
If we think about it,
Akens
is located there, there is a plan
for investments for many years to
come for a primary school very far south,
because geographically it does matter.  We never
want to be sending
students all over the
schools on buses, and we're going to make
adjustments for adjacent schools,
but then when it's too far away, I'm going
to put kids on a bus for 30
minutes to go south.  That's something I do
n't support, and the board won't
support it either.  So, if we are
planning to consider these
moves,
adjustments have been made and we have considered
expansions.
And then there's also what's happening with
Kasy and other schools; there's going to be
movement in all areas.  Once
again, Blure doesn't have a very large area.
If we could turn back time, it
could go much further south.
I wasn't here a long time ago,
but that's what has created this
stress on the system.
Okay, thank you all very much.  I want to
remind you a little bit about the chronology.
This is the process.  We have a plan to
present.
We're having a district-wide conciliation meeting
via Zoom, if you can
join.
So, on Wednesday our
board will have a workshop
where we'll talk about this
draft plan and we'll see all the
cities that have come into our
community.
And that draft plan and the revisions
for that draft will be released this
Friday
and will be ready for
a meeting next Thursday.
So, I just
want to thank
everyone.
So,
I know that they haven't found what they
were looking for, but they
can see.
So, there's
still time to
complete this survey and
comment card using the QR code.
So, what more is there to say?  Yes,
thank you for your time tonight.   I
know it's a big
interruption.  I am very sorry for what we are going
through, that's why I am committed
to it.
Thank you very much for your time.  I am
committed and I will do what I need to
do.  I hope you will stay
with us throughout the process.  Your opinion and
your information are absolutely
important, we care about them.  So
thank you all very much for all of this.